from improvised comedy gold to genuine
babbling blunders these bloopers had us
sticking around and laughing
hysterically during the credits
following his star-making debut on
Saturday Night Live in the 1980s Eddie
Murphy went on to have a fruitful career
in comedies with notable hits like
Beverly Hills Cop and trading places in
1996 he continued that golden streak
with the Nutty Professor a remake of the
1963 classic starring Jerry Lewis Murphy
plays Sherman Klump a morbidly obese man
who in a Jekyll and hyde-esque science
experiment transforms himself into the
overconfident buddy love in order to win
over the woman of his dreams as he does
in a number of his films Murphy takes on
several roles throughout the film
including other members of the Klump
family this results in a couple of wild
family dinner sequences that are as
funny as they are chaotic however the
true hilarity of this scene is best
shown in the end credits outtakes which
depict Murphy breaking character as he
tries to perform each part scored to the
song Macho Man by The Village People the
bloopers feature a number of fart jokes
that make Eddie and the rest of the cast
and crew break down into fits of
laughter
when you manage to get Jim Carrey to be
the face of your studio comedy it's
usually best just to let him go wild on
camera the comedian is known for his
over-the-top improvisations in films
like Dumb and Dumber and The Truman Show
a talent that's on full display during
the end credits blooper reel of Liar
Liar released in 1997 Liar Liar Stars
Carrie as an ethically challenged lawyer
whose son wishes for him to be forced to
tell the truth for one day it provides
lots of great opportunities for Carrie
to shine with physical comedy including
an iconic scene in which he beats
himself up in a bathroom the bloopers at
the end of Liar Liar reveal just how
much fun it was for everyone else on set
to be a witness to Carrie's Brilliance
his improvisations never fail to get the
crew to burst out into hysterical
laughter he's an outstanding comedic
presence on screen as well as a
charismatic leading man no wait I didn't
understand
Hollywood was positive about Carrie's
work in the film too and he scored a
Golden Globe nomination for best
performance by an actor in a motion
picture comedy in a true display of his
range Carrie also ended up with a globe
the following year for best performance
by an actor in a motion picture drama or
The Truman Show
in 2022 Tim Allen reprized his role as
Scott Calvin a family man who inherits
the role of Santa Claus in the Disney
plus series the Santa Clauses however
the story first began in 1994 with the
Santa Claus and Was Then followed up
with two sequels one in 2002 and another
in 2006. the final installment of the
trilogy the Santa Claus 3 The Escape
Clause finds Scott desperate to reclaim
his position as Santa after Mischief
caused by Jack Frost causes him to lose
his job Frost is played by comedy Legend
Martin Short in the film and during the
end credits bloopers audiences can see
the magic that resulted from having two
comedic icons on the screen at the same
time
oh
although The Santa Clause 3 was a
critical failure it performed decently
at the box office regardless it remains
a beloved series set around a joyous
holiday with the end credits bloopers
showcasing a similar kind of fun that
was had on set
despite acting somehow humorous to you
although many moviegoers know Zach
Galifianakis for his appearances in
films like the hangover and due date
those who follow him online are familiar
with the different side of the comedian
his comedy talk show Between Two Ferns
debuted on Funny or Die in 2008
featuring high-profile guests ranging
from Brad Pitt to Barack Obama when it
was announced that Between Two Ferns
would make the jump to feature-length
Comedy many fans of the series were
puzzled as to how it would work as a
longer story nonetheless Between Two
Ferns the movie premiered on Netflix in
2019 and saw Galifianakis play a
fictional version of himself as he
interviews celebrities and tries to keep
his show alive featuring cameos from
celebrities like Brie Larson Keanu
Reeves and Benedict Cumberbatch the film
was subject to decent reviews and
compared to some of the more watchable
Saturday Night Live spin-offs of course
one of the best parts comes during the
end credits when we see some of the
takes that didn't make it into the Final
Cut given that Between Two Ferns
bloopers are hard to come to the point
that it's not always clear whether
Galifianakis is being serious or making
a joke it makes for a heartwarming
ending to see Galifianakis great
character in between insults it seems
like everyone involved had a blast
making the movie especially Paul Rudd
whose improvisations turned Galifianakis
red-faced and hysterical oh
James Franco wears corrective lenses
Bo comedies throughout the early 2000s
how of Saturday Night Live Farrell
starred in critically acclaimed comedies
like elf Zoolander and Anchorman the
Legend of Ron Burgundy his films also
often contain end credits blooper reels
like the first Anchorman movie which
feature Farrell making his castmates
break during improvised scenes following
the success of his earlier films Farrell
teamed up with actor John C Reilly in
2006's Talladega Nights The Ballad of
Ricky Bobby a spiritual successor to
Anchorman centered on the world of race
car driving Farrell plays the titular
Ricky Bobby a NASCAR celebrity whose
life is derailed after he is outshone by
a new driver played by Sasha Baron Cohen
the rest of the Supporting Cast includes
Amy Adams Michael Clark Duncan and Jane
Lynch but this movie's blooper rail puts
the spotlight mostly on Farrell and
Riley 98 of us will die at some point in
our lives the darkness is creeping
towards you whether you know it or not
the two Comics bounce off each other
easily during outtakes of a dinner party
scene and make each other break during
chaotic scenes it's no wonder they
United to make Step Brothers two years
later
Rush Hour was released in 1998 sparking
a multi-million dollar franchise led by
actor star Jackie Chan and Comedian
Chris Tucker the two play an unlikely
pair of cops tasked with rescuing the
kidnapped daughter of a Chinese
politician this film is as thrilling as
it is hilarious and audiences loved it
so much that they kept coming back for
sequels part of what made the rush hour
films such amazing theater going
experiences besides the appeal of the
movies themselves were the end credits
blooper reels each of the three
installments in the rush hour franchise
includes a number of outtakes that are
shown off as the credits roll they're
excellent Showcases of Chan's Charisma
on set as he never misses an opportunity
to be a true Entertainer anything goes
wrong blessing they act like you are lap
[Laughter]
Tucker is also a highlight of the rush
hour bloopers even as he rarely breaks
character though Chan and Tucker may
have seemed like an odd pair before the
release of Rush Hour these end credits
prove that they're actually a match made
in heaven a more recent film that
showcases some quality bloopers is the
2022 Paramount plus original film Honor
Society this movie stars and Gary rice
as honor Rose a type a student
determined to get her advisor's
recommendation to Harvard while
competing with her classmate Michael
played by Gayton Matarazzo of stranger
things Fame her initial plan to seduce
him as a distraction from his studies
goes awry when the two actually fall for
each other in viewing this comedy with
tons of heart and tension however Honor
Society goes down a dark path towards
the end as it's revealed that Michael
had been manipulating honor the entire
time in an effort to secure the
recommendation for himself honor
eventually one-ups Michael by securing
it instead for her friend Kennedy
prioritizing her friendships over both
romance and her own academic success
nevertheless the film closes out with an
end credits blooper reel that leaves
audiences remembering the film's fun
rather than its darker aspects though it
doesn't feature as many outtakes or
improvisational moments from its cast
this kind of end credits real showcases
the chemistry between the film's actors
particularly rice and Matarazzo as its
leads few end credits blooper reels are
as notable as the one shown in the 1979
film being there directed by Hal Ashby
of Herald and mod Fame this classic film
stars Peter Sellers as an oblivious
Gardener who ends up becoming a
political power player after meeting a
rich couple played by Melvin Douglas and
Shirley MacLaine the film was one of
seller's biggest hits and garnered
numerous Award nominations and wins
including a Golden Globe win for Sellers
and a Best Supporting Actor Academy
Award for Douglas though it was more
Uncommon at the time being there ends
with the blooper reel of a single scene
as the credits roll we see sellers
struggle to keep a straight face as he
dryly quotes a man who threatened him at
knifepoint earlier on what was the
message Mr Gardner
now get this honky
even though sellers was seemingly a
shoe-in for best actor at the Oscars
that year the category would eventually
be won by Dustin Hoffman for his
performance in Kramer vs Kramer
according to Douglas's granddaughter
sellers felt the end credits blooper
cost him the award revealing His
Brilliant performance in the film as
exactly that a performance
This is 40 written and directed by Judd
Apatow also features a single scenes
outtakes over its end credits the 2012
comedy mostly centers on Paul Rudd and
Leslie Mann reprising their roles of
Pete and Debbie from apatos Knocked Up
as they grapple with Parenthood
relationship issues and their careers
This is 40 also features an incredibly
robust Supporting Cast including Megan
Fox John Lithgow Jason Siegel Lena
Dunham and Chris O'Dowd but one
particular star shines the brightest
that would be Melissa McCarthy who in
2012 was rolling on the huge success of
Bridesmaids which was released the
previous year in This Is 40 she plays
Catherine a fellow parent at Pete and
Debbie's Children's School who files a
complaint with the principal for their
daughter's behavior in the outtakes
McCarthy goes on a rampaging
improvisation about her violent urges
toward the two stoic parents which
causes Rudd and man to break character
several times I would like to rear up
and jackknife my legs and kick you both
in the jaw with my foot bone
it's no wonder McCarthy became such a
Hollywood comedy Staple in the years
that followed her appearance in Mrs 40
was a precursor to her reign in studio
comedies throughout the 2010s including
Identity Thief the Heat and spy Horrible
Bosses features a powerful sampling of
comedic Talent the 2011 film centers on
a group of three friends played by Jason
Sudeikis Jason Bateman and Charlie Day
whose frustrations with their inept
sociopathic and sadistic bosses result
in them planning to murder their
superiors the movie is not only
hilarious but a surprisingly thrilling
comedic romp involving murder Espionage
and life or death Stakes given the
number of stars and laughs involved it's
no wonder that this film ends with the
blooper reel over the credits the
hilarious Chemistry Between sedakis
Bateman and day is on Full display as
they make each other break down laughing
another highlight includes Colin
Farrell's hilarious improvisations with
a deadpan pharmacist a scene that didn't
make the film's final cut viewers found
the blooper reel so entertaining that
one was included again in the film
sequel Horrible Bosses 2 which also
introduced the town of Chris Pine and
Kristoff Waltz Pixar earned its place in
movie history with a string of hits
starting with Toy Story in 1995. that
was quickly followed up with A Bug's
Life in 1998 and Toy Story 2 in 1999. in
2001 the studio would entrust Pete
doctor to direct his first of many Pixar
films with Monsters Inc which takes
place in a world where monsters Harvest
children screams in order to fuel their
City the film thrives due to its likable
characters with its two leads Sully and
Mike voiced by John Goodman and Billy
Crystal respectively Pixar's animated
blooper tradition began with A Bug's
Life but Monsters Inc was the last of
their Productions to be released with
them in the credits however unlike the
other movies on this list Pixar outtakes
aren't genuine mistakes
ahead go throw up
what what did I say
the outtakes of Monsters Inc that play
through the credits are fully animated
and voice acted including a Toy Story
Cameo and several scenes from the
company play put that thing back where
it came from or so help me this
tradition as brief as it was made
Pixar's characters even more lovable
than they already are
[Music]